so jumping on in um what does it feel
like for you because listen when you
made this movie you don't really know if
people are going to respond to it you
don't know if it's going to be like
people are going to enjoy it you don't
know anything so what does it actually
mean to you to have so many people
loving this movie and i hate using
rotten tomatoes but i checked and it's
like 150 something reviews movies at
like 95
positive i mean that's a very high
number i think it's my highest rated
movie maybe
um well listen i mean i think listen i
of all the movies i've made
like
it's the only one because it's about
kind of like another subject i kind of
think like you'd be cheerless not to
enjoy it like because they're so
entertaining and then work is so
entertaining so
i i
i mean
i'm i'm happy that people are enjoying
it but i did set out to make a film
that was as much an introduction as a
celebration that was
key to it is because i didn't want it to
be
like for sparks fans only
i wanted to sort of introduce them to
people who maybe had missed them or to
people who knew a little bit about
sparks but didn't have a lot of other
context
so
for it to sort of go down well with all
three of those camps is means a lot to
me but
you know and also it's something where
you know like i mean the thing is is
like using the word passion project or
labor of love
um the truth is every movie should be a
past passion project or a labor of love
but this you know and soho both of them
in the same in different ways but this
is something where
i i've liked ron and russell and sparks
for many many years i've always felt
like more people should know who they
were
or understand how influential they were
and how many artists have been
influenced by them
and so making the film was like the best
way of doing that so i you know i made i
made the movie because as a sparks fan
i was aggrieved on their behalf that
they weren't better known
um
you showed the movie you premiered at
sundance
um after the sundance premiere did you
make any tweaks or changes based on what
people said or is the version that
everyone watched the same cut
yeah
i mean
um
i don't think i could even contemplate
like going back into the end no it's the
same version like um the thing we showed
at sundance is is that's it yeah
um what did you this is your first
documentary what did you learn
making this that you would apply if you
were to actually make another
documentary ah that's a good question
um
i think you know i have obviously a
better understanding of what goes into
it
and um
i don't know i think so if i you know it
would it would i would be like
it wasn't that i was necessarily nervous
doing it but like i definitely have a
better understanding of
what it takes and how long it takes
and um
you know i think it was like slightly
different in terms of like to how i do
the fiction films where
i'm really like hands-on and like
standing over people's shoulders in the
sense of you know when me and paul
matchless edit the other movies
we're in the room the whole time we do
it you know like he edits but we're in
the room the whole time
but with this like with portrait arthur
editing
it was it was actually useful for both
of us for me to kind of like
watch it watch a cut frequently or watch
cuts of little pieces
because the way of getting through
something like this where there's like
hundreds of hours of archives and
hundreds of hours of interviews is that
i'd seen all the archive i'd done the
interviews and then i have a pretty good
memory in the i'd done all the
interviews myself and even though there
were transcripts of the interviews i
didn't really need to read them and i
didn't re-watch the footage of the
interviews because i just kind of had it
in my head
who said what so then if cultural arthur
would edit something together
then you know a lot of it would be this
back and forth especially in lockdown we
got the sort of the lion's share of the
work done
in the first lockdown where we couldn't
be in the same room but in a weird way
that was beneficial because i could
watch something give a bunch of notes
speak on the phone he would go away and
do it sometimes he would send me back a
cut the same day so it was this constant
like ping pong and usually i'd watch a
car and i'd say hey didn't uh neil
gaiman say something about this hey
check like mark gattis's interview again
i think he said something about this oh
you know what if if you're gonna use
instead of that clip i'd rather if
that's all we're gonna see of that let's
just use this clip or
so it was just something where
it was a really different way of working
from like my other movies and and and i
think also a really good way of working
where it's just a
an ongoing process
you know like keep looking for bits of
like archive sometimes things would
still kind of show up
very late in the day and you could
incorporate them
um
so that was sort of amazing like there's
a great way of of making it and then
even like at the end of it we had this
concert and it was like
when we have this whole concert let's
let's finish this off as well because
this is like the greatest dvd extra of
all time like a 19-minute concert so the
final thing we did like quite long after
the fact is me and i asked paul arthur i
said let's you know let's kind of like
give this kind of a bit of shape and
sort of so
it can't just kind of like disappear we
have this amazing kind of asset we
should like finish this as a feature in
its own right
the movie is about two hours and 20
minutes what was the cut that you had
above that that you're like i don't know
how we're getting this any
shorter well i think
the assembler letter that i watched was
like nine hours long
and then the next
i gotta pause there that is the longest
assemble edit anyone has ever told me in
terms of you know like sometimes i hear
like you know directors talking about
their assembly cut was three hours or
three and a half hours i've never heard
nine hours
well i mean there was like hundreds of
hours of interview sure i imagine and
also like kind of like more than 50
years to cover
i think then i watched like a um
uh
i watched like a four hour cut which is
one that you could watch in kind of one
sitting
but you know the thing is is that with
this is like yeah if you were making
like a beatles film or bob dylan
artists who were like massive then you
could go to like a you know an hbo and
saying we didn't want to show this in
two parts like no direction home
but because it was sparks it's like sort
of like we need people to kind of watch
this in one hit so it needs to be a
feature so we we all knew that that's
what we was aiming for is to make
something that you could watch as a
feature in one sitting
so and also to be perfectly frank and
then we could have afforded to clear all
of the archive for a four-hour version
so when people say when i mention that
in interviews they're saying when are we
gonna get to see the four hour versions
like i think never because like we just
you can't afford
it's so it's so much work and so much
expense to clear archive
so like we just wouldn't be able to do
it that said on the kind of the blu-ray
we did put a lot of the other footage on
there
there's a lot of great stuff that's on
the blu-ray because there was something
where i i did this slightly different
approach when i was shooting
which um i had ron and russell
revisiting locations
and they were really sweet and it was
sort of the kind of thing you might see
in a sort of bbc documentary like there
was a great alan yento documentary about
the kinks where he just took ray davis
around their first concert venue and
interviewed him and i did some things
where i took ron and russell to previous
locations and they were really sweet and
interesting things but as soon as we
started editing the documentary
that oral history like momentum of
having
hundreds of talking heads talking about
the history of sparks
you you couldn't then just slow down and
do this little vignette of like going
back to the beach or going back to their
mum's shop
so those things kind of hit the cutting
room floor pretty early but it's like
save these like because it's like they
don't fit in the feature but
we should save these as little vignettes
so
we put those all on the blu-ray and and
they're you know nice little um kind of
shorts in their own right
um when you are interviewing someone so
say you're bringing in neil gaiman
mike myers all the people you had when
when you interview them
from the moment they sit down do you
sort of have an understanding like
whatever they say you can use or how
does it work in terms of do you then
send them the footage and say i want to
use this this and this like
you know what i mean
yeah no no i mean
people are coming to talk about sparks
it's not like you're doing
a career thing about them
like um and if there's something that
they said on camera that you know
i mean say hey don't use that bit but
but no you know people sign up sign a
release and they're here to talk about
spark so it didn't have to kind of like
sort of
clear stuff with people you know
sure i'm specifically wondering i really
enjoyed the little bits of mike myers in
the movie and there's a bit where he
like makes a joke about his mole and
like the three-quarter lens and i was
like i'm like did he have to clear that
with mike you know like i think maybe i
did clear that one with mike actually so
i was like just i maybe actually hit the
one person that i did show him some bits
just to make sure he was cool with it
and to his credit he was cool with it
he's got a sense of humor obviously
right is it true or not true that you
made this documentary purely to
interview mike myers
no that's not great
but i love mike and it's it's funny we
we've been like
friends for
a few years now and like sort of and uh
he was like
obviously helped me out and with baby
driver like he gave me the permission to
use the austin powers mask so i've known
mike for a little bit so it's actually
nice to kind of actually do something
with him you know and bizarrely enough
like
i didn't see ron and russell
for the whole of the press in the u.s
because of kobed i was stuck in london
you know sundance was virtual south by
southwest was virtual we did like a
million zooms together
and then they the one place that we were
going to be together to do press was
london
and we were going to do like a we did a
q a
and the one in person q a with the three
of us was in sundance london and that
the night before we went to like a
restaurant in um
london
in marylebone a restaurant we were
sitting outside
and i was sitting with ronald russ and
it was like the first dinner i'd had
with them since the last time i'd seen
them in person
and then as we were having dinner like
russell went oh and looked behind and
standing behind waiting to be recognized
was mike myers
this happens to be staying in
the hotel
with where the restaurant was
and just and said yes i heard your voice
and he and he never met sparks before
um so i introduced ron and russell to
mike myers and paul myers his brother
was there as well so i got a photo of
like the five of us which was just
complete coincidence what are the
chances
of the first time i've had dinner with
ronald russell in
over two years that mike myers happens
to walk by
what is the you obviously traveled the
world what's the craziest place you've
run into somebody that you know like the
most unexpected place oh my god you're
asking some good questions that i don't
have answers for that's a really um
you know what i mean like you're in the
middle of like ireland on the
countryside and you run into your
childhood best friend
you know obviously this is hypocrisy i
had a good story about this i have a
good story about somebody else i have
the best version of the story i can tell
you that instead
edward woodward who's in hot fuzz
is in australia i guess it's when he's
shooting that film breaker morant
and he's hiking with his wife
and this um
other guy is walking towards them and in
australia you can see somebody coming a
mile off
and this guy comes up to him and says
holds out his hand is edward woodward
and uh and edward says oh yeah nice to
meet you and uh you guys what's your
name and he goes i'm edward
he introduced himself as edward woodward
to another edward woodward
so he wasn't coming up to say your
edward woodward he was introducing
himself i'm edward woodward and you guys
that's my name so what are the chances
in australia
in the outback of to edward woodward's
meeting
that i don't have i don't have a story
as good as that one so i mean if it
comes to me later i'll email you
yeah um
yeah i i definitely would not have
expected that story out that yeah
running into anyone in australia in the
outback is the thing is huge
i tell you no i i know i do have a good
story actually um
when i was making hot fuzz
so flashbacks or when i was a teenager
and i first was making films uh amateur
films i was working in a supermarket as
my saturday job
and because i'd been in the local paper
because i'd won a competition on tv
um so i was in the local paper and there
was a
another
stalker who was in my brother's year at
the supermarket and he
his joke once i sort of i was working
you know it's my saturday job i was
working at a supermarket but i was like
had these amateur films and stuff and
this guy darren curtis his joke to me
all the time is i'd be like you know
stacking like cereals and he come up
behind me goes excuse me are you the
famous director edgar wright like that
was his joke whenever i was like doing
some sort of like
like sort of job at him that was his
running joke to come up to me in the
supermarket saying excuse me are you the
famous director i go right
so this is like in like 1994
19 no maybe like 1991-92
cut to
2006
i'm shooting hot fuzz
and we're doing a night shoot in the
street with simon and nick and i am back
in my hometown like doing the film
and i have not seen this guy since
and then
tap tapped up on my shoulder
the same guy darren curtis excuse me are
you the famous shelf stacker edgar
wright
it was like he'd waited
six like 15 years for the payoff of that
joke that's my story
also that's a great story
that's just great shout out to darren
curtis if you're listening
that is great um so when we spoke we
spoke last time with ron and russell uh
i mentioned did you make this doc so you
could hear the music of my the psychic
girl because you had not heard it well
you know what after you mentioned that
in the last interview i did mention it
to them and they said they have it but i
still
i mean i'm actually seeing them tonight
i haven't been in los angeles you know
so i i think i'm not you know so at a
point where i can go over to their house
i think i'd like to listen to it with
them so yes um there is a possibility
that i still have not heard it yet
do you think look obviously they know as
well it hasn't been repurposed for other
stuff either because that sometimes
happens i think whatever they wrote for
that
for the musical still exists and they
didn't like use it for anything else
do you they had as you point out in the
doc they had a number of years in the
early 90s where they were working all
the time but not actually on an album
you know not on a on a record deal so do
you think that they have like in the doc
they talk about how they've written
850 songs i forget the exact number um
but the
do you think they have like hundreds of
songs or like a hundred songs they've
never released have you have you um
spoken to them about that
uh i'm sure there is a lot of stuff that
they haven't released because i don't
think it's something where they look
back
like i know that like um
after they did the album balls in like
2000
they had written another album
and they junked it and did little
beethoven instead and so there's some i
know that sometimes that they've written
an album and said hey we should be doing
something different let's kind of get
rid of this so
i'm sure there is a lot of stuff because
i think in that period they kept on
writing but
i think it's something where they they
they just have an internal momentum
where they can't stop creating like i
know that even like this year in between
doing like the press for
this and and net and
getting ready to talk i know that
they've already written the next album
you know like so i think they just don't
stop i think and that's one of the
things that is astonishing about them is
i think that because they
they're in their 70s but one of the
things that i think has kept them going
is they've never looked down on the pop
song as an art form like some kind of
like bands who are maybe or artists who
sort of like
get older sort of like
feel like they're kind of like previous
work is not beneath them or just the
idea of doing like four-minute songs is
somehow kind of like simplistic and
and and they should be beyond that but i
think ron and russell i think what keeps
them going is they're always
trying to write the perfect spark song
or even the perfect pop song of course
along the way they've written hundreds
of perfect spark songs but i think it's
the thing that keeps them going is that
this kind of this quest
to make music and make the perfect
sparks pop song is like never ending
yeah i mean there's not too many bands
that are uh have made written that many
songs i mean that it's just a huge
number
i just i do wonder though if at some
point they're gonna be like okay so
we're retiring and here's 600 songs
you've never heard you know well i mean
i guess like you know like
prince was like that like there's you
know obviously like we're starting to
hear some of the stuff from the vaults
that you know
i mean it's an interesting thing because
i think sort of like some people are
just prolific like that they can't they
can't stop creating
and you know but then there are factors
that come into it where
you know i think there was a point with
kind of prince where him warner brothers
fell out is because he was being over
productive and they were saying like oh
we don't need like two double albums a
year which is where they kind of i think
came to sort of blows eventually but
some people kind of like
just can't turn the tap off you know
they just keep creating and it's a
fascinating part of what ron and russell
do that like you know sparks is like a
nine to five job for them
oh a hundred percent believe me i've
learned everything about them from the
dock i mean i was going to make a joke
but one of the things that i really love
about the dog maybe ten to six not nine
to five exactly
they have to go jogging in the morning
first yeah yeah i think it literally is
like 10 30 till six
[Laughter]
um one of the things that i love about
the doc is the way you interweave the
animated sequences the claymation that
just the the way you tell the story
using animation how difficult was it to
include that stuff to get it into the
dock and where'd the idea come from in
terms of of using animation
well they've done some animated videos
in their time and in fact there was a
really great one only a couple of years
ago for the song edith pf said it better
than me
that joseph wallace did where he did a
stop-motion animation video with a stop
puppet ronald russell
and the first bit of filming i did for
the movie
um was the concert i shot their concert
in like uh kentucky forum in 2018
and joseph came to the gig the animator
and he brought the puppets with him and
i was like these have to be in the
documentary so that was like the start
of it and then it was there was a couple
of animators but joseph wallace was the
key one doing all the stop-motion stuff
and then we brought in another guy greg
mcleod who had done this amazing
bit of animation for adam buxton if you
look it up online just look up the tony
visconti david bowie brian eno sketch by
adam buxton it's just a hilarious bit of
animation
so i basically obviously as well there
are things within the archive where i
mean there it's sorry there are stories
told in the documentary where there is
no archive um and i just felt because we
had so much other great historical
archives that it'd be great to show
animation for bits that where there just
was no
and then also just because
ron and russell are so visual and you
know have a background not just in
filmmaking because russell studied at
ucla but ron studied graphic design and
it's been a big part of their obviously
their album covers are like such a huge
part of what they do um it just seemed
like a no-brainer to sort of think and
to incorporate lots of different styles
of animation cut out stop-motion
claymation traditional line drawing like
a little manga sequence
um
you know that that sequence was done by
some of the animators from scott pilgrim
there's like literally one bit where
it's like hey we don't have any footage
for the miler psychic girl project
collapsing why don't we get some artists
to do
a manga
strip for that
yeah and by the way it looks um listen
man you know i love this movie um my
last thing is i think i'm basically out
of time the
i don't think people realize the
importance of clearance and like
clearance issues in terms of making a
documentary and i'm just curious were
there things that you wanted to include
that you ran into
we can't clear this like we
there's rights issues
not really um
no more the thing is like there were a
couple let me listen the the truth is is
that the the clearance and the archive
and the music
is like a herculean task like just
mind-boggling and like kate griffiths
with who is this archive producer and
also laura richardson who was one of the
producers on the movie
um
and their whole team just did so much
work right up until the release of the
film like gotten me dumping the eyes and
crossing the t's and that's that's why
you'll never see a four-hour account
it's just like that is so much work
anybody who's made a documentary archive
knows what an incredible amount of work
is because they're coming from all over
the world those clips it wasn't so much
there were some things that we just
could not find there were a couple of
like key tv appearances
in like america and the uk
that had long been wiped and we were
sort of maybe hoping that you never know
somebody might find something in their
attic but there is a couple of like sort
of i mean luckily there's so much other
stuff but i was maybe thinking like you
know like like a key tv appearance like
their first american bandstand
appearance or their first appearance on
this show called the old grey whistle
test that they might show up in the
process but you know sometimes those
things are just gone i mean that's the
thing that people like just don't you
know didn't understand back then is the
value of like
every keeping everything you know
lots of
tv companies said hey we haven't got
room for these quarter inch tapes let's
wipe it
i i think about all the johnny carson
episodes that are just gone
there's tons of like um you know the bbc
used to have a policy which is now
thankfully gone where they were trying
to kind of like save space in the
archives so they decided with some
comedy shows to keep the first and the
last episodes and wipe the rest
and it happened and the some shows like
monty python's flying circus luckily
because they've been sold to
other countries all of those exist
there was doctor who episodes that got
wiped there were many many episodes of
top of the pops that got white
you know peter cook and dudley moore's
show not only but also there were three
seasons of it and there's only like six
episodes that remain which is like a
crime against comedy you know
completely listen i gotta stop there but
i am gonna say it again um
this stock is one of my favorites films
of the year i mean i can't say enough
good things about it man and um you know
i'm glad so many people love it like me
and thank you for your time